[Music]
good morning Myron morning Daryl let's
go right to the heart of the matter what
most people remember about your Nobel
Prize in Economics is that it led to a
precise mathematical formula for the
price of an option and we'll get into
the story of that and in a couple of
minutes but for those of you know
watching that don't know a whole lot
about finance what exactly is an option
at question basically an option is the
right but not the obligation to buy a
security at a fixed price over a set
period of time that's called a call
option and there's also other options
which give you the right but not the
obligation to do so to sell the security
at a set price over a specified time
period so the interesting thing about
options are basically they are rights or
ability to do something without the
requirement to do something so it's the
flexibility or the optionality that we
think about in life and it's a similarly
it applies to securities as well so it
could be equities could be bonds could
be commodities correct equities bonds
commodities commitments a lot of
different things okay so now let's go
way back in time think of yourself in
the late 1960s and a lot of things were
going on in finance around that time
major developments in the you know
emerging field of financial economics a
lot of people had worked on how to price
an option was a hard problem and I'm
just curious to hear how you actually
got involved in this I mean what was it
that triggered your interest in solving
this really hard problem well that's
that's an interesting a long involved
question but basically when I was at the
university cago as a PhD student that
was a barrier as you mentioned a very
embryonic time for the development of
finance it was a completely different
way of looking at finance mostly from an
economic perspective is
opposed to a rules-based perspective and
it led to the development of finance as
part of economics really and which was
much different from the finances being
an ancillary sort of rules based way of
thinking about things so at that time
there was a great understanding of how
to manage risk and the idea of thinking
about risk as the idea of buying risky
assets versus safe assets that was one
dimension of risk management and the
other dimension of risk management was
diversification you know how you would
diversify risky assets and that led to
development of things such as Bill
sharps great discoveries and
amplification of Markowitz his work and
talking about the capital asset pricing
model and that for us was a great
breakthrough because it was an
equilibrium model of how assets
individual assets should be priced
relative to a benchmark or asset
portfolio and and that was one strand
that was very prevalent so that
combination of risk and how to think
about risk but no one had really yet had
thought about risk from the dimension of
insurance in our area a lot of people
have talked about insurance from an
actuarial way actuarial science they had
talked about pricing insurance from the
idea of thinking about it only in the
form of an option as I described how to
value an option but no one had really
thought about in terms of an equilibrium
context or thinking about how it fit in
to how assets were held how they were
priced in the dynamics and that
fascinated me when I before I went to
MIT as an assistant professor and when I
went to MIT as an assistant professor it
was mandatory at the time that master's
students in the and the Sloan program
the master's program had to write a
thesis and
several students came to me and asked me
to be their advisor and they had option
pricing data from the over-the-counter
market and using that data they wanted
to price options so basically they
wanted to use the capital asset pricing
model which we had discussed in our
classes and apply that to the option
terminal values to discount it to
present value and look at the value of
the option when I started reading the
theses and thinking about it much more
deeply I realized that although it might
be easy to get they expected terminal
who the option it was impossible to
think about discounting it back to
present value by using a constant
discount rate because the risk of the
option changed dramatically as a
function of time and as a function more
importantly of how the underlying asset
price change relative to the strike
price of the option you have a way in
the money option it behaved almost like
the stock and a pure elaborate
instrument and then basically as it was
out of the money that moved very little
with regard to changes in the underlying
stock or asset price so that got me
thinking again about options and then I
started reading a lot of the literature
on options that existed Paul Kohner who
was a faculty member here at Stanford as
well came under the Bill sharps auspices
and he had passed away in the guess in
the late 70s here but he had written a
book or had a compendium of articles on
option pricing in his book and read
through all of them all the articles
plus the literature and none were very
satisfying because they didn't have any
any really equilibrium model or
equilibrium thinking about option
pricing so that's how I started in
thinking about options and then I
thought about the idea of saying what is
in economics we think about equilibrium
and how do you think about one asset
price relative to another and how
the dynamics of that assets price would
evolve over time and since I was
schooled and enamored with and in love
with the capital asset pricing model and
what it implied about its risk and
assets risk and how that assets risk
would be priced it became obvious to me
that you know that I should think in
terms of the beta of the asset so the
beta is the idea of how the returns on a
particular asset are related to some
market portfolio equilibrium portfolio
and all assets should be differential
expected return just based on the
proportionality or the beta of that
asset regarding its relation to the
market portfolio at least over a very
short period of time and so thinking in
that way I said well let me just think
of I can think what the beta of this
option is okay that would be and so then
I would know what the expected return
would be on the option for the next
period of time and how it related to the
market itself and then I thought about
this idea of the hedging or the selling
one and buying the other and you know
that's when I then started talking with
Fischer black who became what I was
working with in other projects and we
then started to he had been thinking
about options as well and working on
options in on his own independently of
me and then we joined forces together
and he was visiting MIT at the time no I
assure black actually I met Fischer
black in the fall of 1968 when I am
dating myself and I'm making myself very
old which I have I know your boy
basically I came to MIT and Michael
Jensen who was
a colleague of mine not a colleague of
mine a fellow student of mine at the
universe Chicago had met Fischer black
because Fischer black had was working at
Arthur D little as a consulting firm and
then had asked Michael questions about a
study that he was that he Fischer black
was working on and he said Michael said
that I should have lunch with him so I
phoned him up and we had lunch together
and in the meantime I had talked with
Wells Fargo Bank in the summer of 68
before I went to MIT about their
management science group and what they
had been doing in terms of using
Markowitz technology to build optimal
portfolios when I wrote my report they
had had wonderful technology and being
able to build use covariance matrices
and figure out the efficient portfolio
however they had no inputs to put in to
the model and they had very few clients
that they could use any of what they had
done on this was Harry Markowitz who
also got a Nobel Prize yeah Harry
Markowitz also has had a Nobel Prize for
with Merton Miller and with bill Sharpe
in 1990 but he had but so I recommended
to them that they think about moving to
passive strategies because they had
nothing to lose by doing that and I just
felt that at the time from studies that
might Jenson had done and others that
just buying a portfolio and not trying
to act a management back portfolio could
do was approximately as well as passive
portfolios at least from the data and
doing it at much less cost and so I that
was the end of my project and later in
December of that year Wells Fargo phoned
me up Mac McLeod and said we'd like you
to do more Studies on this idea of this
passive portfolio idea and I said well
I'm gonna young assistant professor I'm
stuck here and I'm
I can't travel but I have this fellow
Fischer black who I had talked with and
enjoyed my discussions and he wants to
set up his own firm which was called
associates and Finance and he then
became with me we go talk with Wells
Fargo and developed a lot of empirical
tests to verify that passive investing
you could do approximately as well as
investing with an active manager and I
think that was sort of the genesis of
for the institutional side the genesis
of the idea of passive investing which
later been called index investing or ETF
investing and it was the case that
Vanguard in 74 put out the first
individual index fund the S&P 500 index
fund but Wells Fargo was really the one
that started off in 68 and later built a
huge business and now black Blackstone
Blackrock has the ETF business ETF
business that all generated from that
particular Genesis so Fischer black and
I were doing a lot of empirical research
and trying to show that that these were
this was at efficacy you can do it you
know
and through that we thought about we
discussed myriad things we wrote a lot
of papers together was kind of great to
be doing research and thus getting and
doing publishing things at the same time
is trying to think about building this
this wing of investments in finance and
we talked then talk I talked to Fisher a
lot about options and he talked to me
about his views and options and that's
how the partnership was born
he's said to be an interesting person
what what was it like on a personal
level to work with Fischer black Fischer
Fischer black evolved over time when
Fischer black was wonderful to work with
when I was working with a my I always
felt that his ideas were you know he's
was a genius and in myriad ways and you
know he would argue his points but he
was very very strong and Arnie's
points but it's very male once he agreed
with you he would switch you know and
come to agree with you and then amplify
and why do you were saying so he was I
was more evolved voluble you know
talking a lot and he was listening you
know and listening and then he would
intervene and I'd say okay that's great
and you know we would move off in that
direction I almost visualize your two
guys hammering away at the chalkboard
I'm working on that formula what you
know I know it's mathematically a very
deep subject but was there some kind of
lights went on and some kind of
breakthrough idea that you had that
allowed you to to actually come up with
the formula well I think it's science I
don't know maybe from your own
experience in your own research you you
have a different view but a lot of
people believe in in your Rica moment
and all of a sudden the lights go on but
a lot of science and a lot of what we
did was connectivity
connecting various pieces together and
you know thinking about the various
pieces and then that connectivity
because it's all in your mind
it connects so maybe there is quoting a
Rica moment where you see the
connectivity but a lot of it as I said
in the introduction came from the view
of thinking about you know what the
beauty of the capital asset pricing
model what others had done like Merton
Miller and Merton Miller and Franco
Modigliani views on capital structure
and you know how they thought about
arbitrage you know that idea in their
papers they had the idea of you can't
you know that debt in a firm like
there's a PI concept you have debt and
equity and you have the assets so you
can't have the debt being dependent of
the assets and the equity they off to be
tied together and so all those things
were in the mind you know and they were
all fresh and they were in live because
that was so new to everyone at that time
and I'm now if people are studying it in
class it's all old you know self but
it's but that time was all like just
everything was so exciting and it's
exciting for you but as you said at the
time probably not that many people
understood the significance of what you
discovered and how important it would
eventually become for the practice
finance I heard maybe this is some just
a rumor that you actually had difficulty
getting that paper published when you
first submitted it well is that true yes
actually it was when Fisher and I first
submitted our paper it was rejected
myriad times okay it was rejected as
being either too arcane or insignificant
for finance and when it was finally
after the intervention of Merton Miller
and gene fama to tell the journal of
political economy that they should look
at the paper again after having rejected
it they finally came back and said that
they would publish it and I think I'm
not sure if this is a hundred percent
accurate but I think it has been the
most cited paper in the history of the
journal of the color column it's
probably one of the most cited papers in
all of economics so thank you so you you
you've discovered the formula you wrote
the paper that somewhere after you got
the formula Bob Merton comes into the
picture he was interested in the same
problem tell us a story about your
discussions with Bob and what he
eventually did because he also got the
Nobel Prize with you yes very definitely
I'm in science you know we're a little
bit like hunters okay so Fisher and I
her husband what we did we try to work
and get as far as we could and what we
were working on together without
broadcasting it or telling other people
what we were working the hunter you know
make sure that he doesn't tell where the
fish are okay and when Bob Merton who is
a colleague of mine at MIT came into my
office and was talking about his
continuous time finance and the idea of
thinking about you know the hedging
portfolios that he was working on and
developing at that time was very
important I said great Bob keep working
on that because both Fisher and I knew
that Samuelson alone and then Samuelson
and Merton had written papers on option
pricing a warrant pricing
and we knew that there was fundamental
assumptions and their papers that were
incorrect you know and we wanted to have
because of our discovery and we wanted
to move as far along as we could in 1970
Wells Fargo had a conference that they
sponsored at MIT and you know all of us
people were brought in from around the
war around the country the world wasn't
at that time involved in finance like it
is today but at the time so we had like
Bill sharp would come in and you know
Michael Jensen and others for example
and Somerton Miller and the like so we I
I was to give it the opening paper of
the second day of the conference you
know and I was gonna open what we had
done and discuss with what we had done
with group and I as it was for me and
Fisher it was you know here was a great
group of people to introduce it to and
Bob Merton was supposed to come but he
overslept so he didn't hear that he
didn't hear the paper okay at that time
about a couple of weeks later he came
into my office and he said I heard you
gave this paper at this conference on
you had a exact formula to price an
option and he said I think that's
impossible
you know I mean it can't be true so I
explained to him I put up how they are
hedging worked and their capital asset
pricing model and I showed I showed the
differential equation to him and he
looked at it and said no no could you
still have a systemic component that you
haven't got rid of in the Florida that
has to be part of the pricing so the
idea of the brilliance of what was
discovered was when he went through this
inductive approach to value an option as
opposed to the adaptive approach
everyone had taken the deductive
approach trying to figure out what the
terminal value of the option was and
bring it back to present value what we
did is said no you don't have to do that
you can do it each period of time
inductively and then
not you know at that time and then that
would be give you the valuation and so
he you know said no that was not didn't
work you know there's an error in that
and so we argue which is great when you
have wonderful colleagues as you know
for your career as well as mine that
having colleagues around that you can
talk to about things and our UFO curious
things really enhances the value for
everyone you know and then so in talking
to him or going through things says you
know I said look as we use the capital
asset pricing model is a way to do
things for the simple reason that we
believe in equilibrium pricing so if the
capital asset pricing model applied
every instant of time you know then
you'd have an equilibrium every instant
of time and then you could figure out
how every asset was priced relative to
every other asset and that would mean
that you would be able then to have this
sequence of correctly priced assets in
the market and you could head you then
and and figure out from that how the
differential equation came about so I
explained that everything to Bob okay
and that and then he argued that not was
not true and then the argument was what
is what does it mean every instant of
time or every short period of time and
how close you get to be innocent of time
and then he's left the office and I
would a midweek sometimes these things
are so vivid because you respect
someone's brilliance and its ability to
argue with you and talk to you and then
I'm midweek and then on Saturday he
phoned me at my house and he said that
he agreed now that our formula was right
and he used Ito calculus and use we
didn't use the stochastic calculus to
come to our gala nobody did it no I did
it that time
right so use the fasted calculus to
achieve you know an exact result which
he then showed there was actually the
replication if you believed in the
generating processes of ito processes
that he had used that it was exact
replica exactly replicated you know I
think Fisher and I have argue with Bob
over the years you know that we liked
our initial formulation better than the
Ito calculus or the continuous-time
framework because of the ability of us
to allow for pricing to change in the
economy and that you would then be able
to have you know every asset having to
be priced correctly and held and that's
we didn't have to assume that but we had
to he argue that we assume the capital
asset pricing model applied in
continuous time or in very short periods
of time but so anyways and you know his
his work and his evolution and then he
formalized many more components than we
had done once you show where the gold is
in them Hills you know it's very hard
once you have your stake for others not
to continue to stake out lots of
different parts as well and try to find
more gold and there was a lot of gold
that was available time and they are in
pricing technology I read that he
generously held up the publication of
his next paper on option pricing so that
your paper would get priority because
you were first is that right correct
yeah he did I mean he had his original
is extension 's and what he had done is
published in the Bell Journal of and
they're ready to go and then the because
we kept getting rejected and asking for
revisions you know that basically the
Journal of economy published our paper
in May of 73 finally so changing gears
just a bit as I mentioned earlier most
people who don't who are not deeply
immersed in finance do know that there's
this famous option pricing formula but
right in the title of your paper it says
that your formula could be applied to
price corporate debt right
and that's now one of the most important
applications of the formula did you
notice that at the same time that you
came up with a formula or before and you
were trying to solve both problems or
did it occur to you after your priced
options that you could at the same time
calculate the market value of a debt
claim on a corporation Wow once okay
once Fisher and I had the option pricing
formula came up with a pricing formula
then we idea of an option which is the
right to and not the obligation to do
something then both of us started
talking in every direction about our
lives were options were everywhere you
know in other words you it's going
through the forest if you start focusing
on something you know you'll see things
in myriad different ways and if you go
somewhere else through the forest and
focus on something completely
differently and as a result I remember
our taking vacations together and
walking on the beach you know and just
talking talking talking about how
options were and how we can apply what
we had done to other things as well and
it became obvious because of you know
Franco Modigliani and Merton Miller's
work on the idea of capital structure
but they and their capital structure
work only had it be for a riskless debt
well and not risky debt and then so we
talked about that and how our our work
when applied to risky debt as well and
why debt equity to us became an option
you know the equity holders had the
right to buy back the firm from the debt
holders by paying off on the debt
obligation and a no-fault bankruptcy
world you know if they didn't they just
turned the keys over to the debt holders
and and they would take over so
basically the arguments that Miller and
Modigliani held at least in a
frictionless world applied in the same
thing if you had risky debt as you had
non risky debt but the
important thing in the debt contract was
that with risky debt the there was a
whole number of incentives that would
come into play and there was a friction
between the debt holders and the equity
holders because if they changed the risk
of the assets that could affect the debt
holders differentially from the equity
holders and basically if the firm got in
the trouble then if they issued equity
that would increase the value of the
debt etc and so that was so exciting to
talk about and think about it as you
know your work over time as you
formalize those things so that that
became a very important part so we
talked a lot about that and actually in
once you had the basic formula to price
an option then you obviously had the
basic formula the dynamics the price a
debt contract but unlike the option
contract which we can think is
isomorphic whether you're above it and
you're watching it when you got to the
firm and thinking about the firm can do
then there was this war between the debt
holders and the equity and they could
change the characteristics of the assets
or the evolutionary process of the
assets that would affect debt and equity
they get a dividend policy they can have
issuing more data or etc or buying back
equity and so all the covenants would
come in and so that was a rich area that
led to many papers and and Bob Merton
formalized a lot of that and what he had
written on in his paper something of
that so we did describe how to price you
know a debt contrast simple debt
contract as that in an extension because
um so we had tried to do was we
published initial paper we just thought
about it as being a piece you know we'd
have this sequence of other papers and
we'd have us repair an assistant
professor now I'm going to send some
faster having papers so once you have a
train you want to have published more
but you know I didn't you realize that
once you expose a whole new area that's
that people will that then take up I
remember giving the paper here at
Stanford University coming here
it's a Berkeley Stanford joint seminar
so it was like 150 people in the
audience you know they're listening to
the black-scholes paper and a lot of
people obviously because was so unusual
to think you can value something in
finance without having to know what the
expected return was that we were shocked
in the audience you know it was and -
and so there was those things so this is
false but I remember mark Rubinstein
coming up to me after the seminar was
over and Mark said he said this is going
to change the whole nature of finance
and I I didn't it was right he was right
I didn't know that it had ended up a lot
of avenues yeah so speaking of that
moving ahead through time like about 25
years later the phone rang early in the
morning yeah they were calling from
Stockholm I suppose yes Oh tell us about
that phone call how did you react to
that well it's actually I was in Pebble
Beach giving a talk as you know remember
and it was okay yeah obviously
everything is always a shock to you when
you have you have the phone ringing and
people say you've been awarded that
prize I had unfortunately Fisher black
had passed away in 1995 two years
earlier and I have thought that you know
because people said that your work was
possibly going to be awarded the prize
and you know it's interesting that ever
even though the expectation might be
high there's an error to the expectation
and right and you never know you never
know year any given year even if it's
likely you'll get the prize at some
point you don't know which year it's
correct so it must have been quite a
shock it was a shock and also and I had
thought that you know obviously the
first thing I had thought about was
great that Bob and I were awarded the
Nobel Prize but then I haven't moaned
the fact that you know Fischer had
passed away and wasn't going to
participate as well and then you had to
go to Stockholm
correct and there's
big event the king is there kind of take
us back paint the picture of of what
this event was like for you and and what
happened right well it's uh it was new
for me in the sense that I went to
Stockholm and everything is very well
prepared they have a playbook because
they had about a hundred or so years of
experience and so they know everything
and the order of everything's gonna
happen I was just this person that's
there and the like but it's um it's very
a great ceremony because they combined a
combination of fur viola D in other
words you know the students have skits
and preparations they also have ceremony
you know where the king and queen of
Sweden award the prize in and the and
they have a banquets that follow
informal banquets and they also have
serious scholarship you know you give
seminars at various universities in in
Sweden and so in the combination of the
scholarship the fruit of ecology and the
ceremony is a pretty rich experience i
when I returned home after the whole
affair you know I given me before a
driver and tache and you know you had
your own cars and everyone would watch
you in Stockholm as you're going through
Stockholm so it was a very important
event for those people in Stockholm in
Sweden
generally and so I got into the backseat
of my car
expecting my car to go to the
supermarket to buy my food and that and
it obviously didn't go anywhere so I had
to go in the front but they're
fascinating fascinating is everyone in
the press always asks you about what are
you going to do with the prize money now
at the time at the time the prize was
approximately 1 million dollars and
obviously had to
split it with robert merton so he
received 500,000 and then the united
states government they wanted about
250,000 of my 500,000 but i you've been
in stockholm and it's very expensive so
i had to bring my family and and pay for
their airfare and their dresses and all
the other things they needed to wear for
the ceremonies and the like and so i
think when I got home maybe I had about
thirty two thousand dollars left of the
money to either spend on myself or
invest so one of the Nobel Prize winners
Phillips who was worth a Nobel Prize
with it
Steven Chu is actually was saying you
know as the Stanford physics professor
was awarded the prize in the same year
there was three who were awarded the
prize in Finnick
they said he belong the fact to me that
actually he lost money because what
surprised in three the treadmill ward
the awarded the prize itself is ignoring
or forgetting the monetary value is so
huge because your life changes so
dramatically after that
well it's certainly I mean you didn't
need the prize to validate the impact of
your of your contribution so speaking of
that yeah another quarter century has
passed almost and the world has been
changed a lot by the work that you did
almost fifty years ago
help us understand that legacy what you
know what's going on in finance today
that had you not discovered this prized
part of me had you not discovered this
this breakthrough formula in this
methodology for pricing options and for
pricing corporate debt what would be
different today what's the legacy of
what you did
conditional on others not discovery
because you know I always worry about
that that someone once you discover
something that you know you have to
publish it because others will discover
as well but look I think that it changed
the whole nature of Finance and
and you know in applications of Finance
to practice okay because when I we
started off in the business then the
investment banking world for example or
insurance companies or banks were all we
are just marrying together buyers and
sellers they were just sort of agents
okay and once the technology was
developed technology was developed they
then move from the world of agency to
being principle in part and they
innovated in so many different ways to
make things faster for clients when
you're just an agent you have to find a
buyer and a seller they can if they
could act as a principal in part and
hedge their risk and learn how to use
quantitative techniques and and in what
they were doing it just lets go through
during a concrete way I'm a client of
whatever Goldman Sachs right I called
them up and I say I have this corporate
or personal investment problem I'm what
do I do
I mean where does the work that you did
come into the solution for a problem and
give me an example of a problem all
right
example of that might be that a
particular corporation might want a
security that would pay off in different
states okay under different conditions
and that would not be a standard form
contract it would be for their they
might have oil or they have different
things they would be willing to pay off
more on if that if oil prices were
higher than lower so that's not already
traded on an exchange option say Goldman
has to kind of manufacture that
contingent claim for you correct
and how does your how does your work
help them figure out how to do that how
much to charge you for that right well
charging part I don't know there's
obviously that a charging part first is
what the value increment would be that
how much I'm willing to pay for the
solution that befits me versus the one
my shoe size
versus having one shoe fit all that they
all the old way of doing things was one
shoe fit all you know you just had a
standard contract and then as you can
make things more individualized the
value to me increases but then with a
charge or the pricing of that depends on
competition and Goldman would be doing a
tour JP Morgan would be doing it is etc
the same way so as the technologies
development people know what the pricing
comes down because you know then
everyone can learn and copy from each
other so we're all better off you know
and how we're using it but
individualization of is Damas that the
manufacturing process became not one a
manufacturing process became one of
saying okay we will issue this claim
that you have to a client that we have
but that client doesn't want to buy what
you want okay but we will give the
client what they want and we will hedge
the risks on our own so go goldman would
then act as an intermediary they would
buy the claim that the corporation
wanted to issue and they would sell
another claim to someone else who wanted
to buy something else and then they'd
have to figure out how to handle the
middle part which is the excess risks of
the excess pieces that weren't matched
in the match and then they would use the
technology derivative technology to be
able to hedge that risk and to be able
to manufacture by going to the capital
markets and buying things you've done
obviously a lot of research on your own
I'm thinking about these hedging
technologies and how they would apply to
the intermediating business so it
changed the nature of intermediation
quite dramatically and that attracted a
lot of quantitative people a
quantitative interest in coming to
investment banks and finance
generally so there there seemed to be no
end of applications of what you've done
look looking forward do you foresee some
new kind of technology for finance that
either enhances what you did or takes us
in a completely new direction going
forward well I I don't know if I'd say
it's a completely new direction but I do
think of it as being a way to think
about using what we know in a different
way and what I mean by that is one of
the great findings sort of sort of like
the arrow-debreu technology or the state
pricing technology they built a
technology that try to price risk in
various states so instead of thinking
about a riskless world we thought about
a risky world where the prices of assets
would change cross-sectionally depending
on the state of nature that arose not an
interesting thing is that that had
myriad states and period prices and just
as we had thousands of goods around the
world today well that technology the the
option pricing technology if you believe
there are certain state variables like
the like growth assets or interest rate
assets allows you to be able to
economize on pricing and everything
becomes price relative to the evolution
of the state prices the interesting
thing is that what we observe in the
option prices or market prices is the
prices of insurance okay and if you look
at the prices of insurance they're not
constant over time they're changing over
time that means that the risk is
changing over time and if the risk is
changing over time the distribution of
risk are changing over time then we have
to now give up the one period models
that we have been using or
in a one period model I mean in an
evolutionary sense we just assume you
know that the evolution is no honor that
and that calibration is constant and
then figure out how to use the
information in the market prices to
decide on then how to change the way we
think about capital budgeting decisions
the way we think about discounting the
way we think about portfolio management
so you know there's tremendous amounts
of dynamics that are left to still work
on in our area which I think using the
basic framework and the value of prices
that we see in the market to really
enhance our ability to understand those
things that we know that that it we
can't assume that we're drawing from the
same earn each period of time you know
you need your self have done a
tremendous amount of thinking about what
happens at times of shock you know in
which and how price has changed
dramatically and so we can start
incorporating some of those and more
directly in what we're doing and I think
those are tremendous growth areas ahead
yeah speaking of shocks those finance is
often associated with big shocks to the
economy associated with financial crises
financial instability but with what
you've described this morning I I hope
that those watching will understand that
research discoveries like yours can
improve society can add a lot of value
to the real economy by providing
solutions that weren't otherwise
available and I really want to thank you
for coming in today and and going over I
know it's old history but going over how
this how this came about so thanks again
oh you're welcome dear thank you very
much and really appreciate it yeah
you